I was just about to start you're gonna
leave all right here you go okay
is this what we're doing okay good
choice hi guys I'm Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra's never seen and today I
am watching Back to the Future Part 2 as
always I'm very excited I loved Part 1 a
ton and I really think it's gonna be
just like on par it was just such a good
idea let's see how you all know you know
what happens I don't I'm the one that
does it though Oh Tanner has never seen
Ike roads where we're going we don't
need roads well it was so good no
disappointment nothing terrible I loved
it so much as always I love everything I
love I know that these movies aren't
technically like one two and three it's
like supposed to be a whole thing that
you watch together and I really enjoy
that aspect of it it feels like it's a
TV show and tune in next week next week
tune in next week to find and I think
that's really cool
I love the new and improved DeLorean
time machine runs on like garbage and it
hovers instead of drives and it's so
good and well thought out and of course
you went to the Future so of course it's
gonna be better than it was just so
they're in 2015 and they're freaking out
it's a lot of fun and Doc Brown puts
Marty's girlfriend Jennifer to sleep
with like a little spritz because she
got a little excited if that happened to
me every time that I got excited I would
just always be asleep though I feel like
they understand as effective it a little
bit because like Doc Brown is wearing a
see-through tie and that is like the nut
most 90s thing I've ever seen in my life
so they did technically get that
prediction right it was just a little
under shot something I love about this
movie is that there's a lot they bring
in from the first you literally revisit
the first movie but it doesn't feel
repetitive it doesn't feel like like
marty is still this really cool
heartthrob and like the bad guys you see
at the beginning
and movie are like ridiculous and
over-the-top and it's similar to the
first but it just they make it feel
really new but like I said the bad guys
are nuts like one of them has a weird
computer circuit lines just drawn on his
face for some reason they talk like
maniacs and like big jr. is legitimately
on coke like no doubt definitely on coke
then you find out that Einstein is still
alive so my hopes and dreams are as well
the future police find past Jennifer
passed out and take her to her future
home she's no good because her future
self is there then they take her to her
home and you see all of the actors
playing themselves as older or younger
versions and it's so much flippin fun
way more fun than if they got a younger
actor older actor to play them I just
really loved it I recently learned that
Crispin Glover was not in this movie and
I didn't I didn't know like the drama
behind all of that but I just I just
found out and they did a really good job
with like making it seem like he was in
the movie I know they got in trouble for
it which they probably should but I just
had no idea also Michael J Fox is an
attractive woman just throw that out
there and then yeah
who are you I can't hear you damn I look
good what are you wearing I'd said
turtleneck it was like really hot in
here you're very sweaty yeah well I got
some really rude comments in the last
video so I just thought I would yeah no
we don't worry about that in the future
no yeah but I just thought they'd go so
don't let little boys police your body
you were comfortable in the last year
he'll make guys can go topless in a
video you can wear a tank top I see we
haven't stopped saying no we're so cool
we really are so how is the pond like
from like eight minutes in the future
but you eat a sandwich after this video
sort of like really
good anyways bye-bye didn't think I was
gonna dress that did you anyways I think
it's weird that Marty's one character
flaw and this movie is that he can't be
called chicken without freaking out
listen mark as I previously addressed
people can call people some really mean
things but chicken that's the one you're
gonna get caught up on it's where it
ruins everything so they go back to the
past but it's not the right past because
of the sports Almanac that Marty
wrongfully gets so the back of the 80s
and Biff is super powerful in this
version of this time and he marries
Marty's mom and like there's this awful
scene of him like forcing her to kiss
him and like I just don't like her
chemistry together at all it's not
chemistry it's sexual assault and this
is literally Donald Trump that's what I
wrote in my notes right here Biff is
literally Donald Trump and then I found
out that there's like a bunch of
articles on how like the author actually
used him as an inspiration for the
character of if I don't know if it's
true or not but there's a bunch of
articles about it so it's online where
everything is factual and accurate and
they leave Jennifer in this hellscape of
the 80s that they're in and it's awful
why they're she's like passed out on
this hammock and they leave her they're
so rude I had to change the batteries so
hopefully the same track so there's a
bunch of back-and-forth but Marty ends
up getting the sports Almanac that ruins
the future from Biff and from the
principal but then he ends up ruining
the first movie Marty's timeline so he
has to fix that it's all very
time-travel II and parallel universe II
and confusing in an excellent way so
then Marty fixes everything
but then Biff ruins everything because
he calls him a chicken and Marty gets
mad and Biff gets the book back why
can't you handle being called a chicken
why this is literally my one problem
with the film the whole chase scene
between Biff and Marty getting the book
back is really cool with the old car and
the hoverboard is a cool
contrast with each other and I love that
it ends with him getting his car filled
with manure again I love it it's so good
again like it could be repetitive it
could get really repetitive with the
things they brought back but it didn't
at all babies like manure
I hate manure well it's a pretty
unpopular opinion Biff so everyone else
loves him anyway and then everything's
fixed yay and then there's lightning boo
things after this happened just like
really rapid fire like dog Brown is gone
and Marty's stuck in the past and then
this weird car shows up and he gets a
letter from the 1800s and it's Doc Brown
and he's living in the eighteen hundreds
of like the wild wild west and it's all
very exciting and the third movie is now
going to take place in the wild wild
west and I loved West things and I'm
very excited from the looks of a little
but from the looks of the little teaser
trailer that they show it could either
be really really super fun or just go
like way off the rails but I had a blast
with this one and I can't imagine also
I've heard that it's good so I think I'm
just really excited to watch it I also
love that the teaser trailer says coming
in 1990 you guys it only took me 26
years to see this movie I got there it
happened
so a couple things what was the point of
Jennifer weird that she was there is she
gonna be a bigger part in the third one
and then again I don't like the
sexual-assault vibe that I get from Biff
and Marty's mom I don't like that one
bit not one bit if it was super fun it
could have easily been a weird sequel
that wasn't as good but again not
repetitive really like I am being by
saying that a hundred times it was super
fun I liked it almost if not the exact
same amount as I liked the first which
is a huge amount so I'm really stoked to
see the third one
can't wait it's gonna be super fun super
great see you guys next week gun joke
Oh
[Music]